if you just finished watching netflix's
new animated film the witcher nightmare
of the wolf you might be a little
confused even if you're a fan of the
franchise so let's explore some of the
biggest unanswered questions posed by
the animated spin-off
if all of the witcher you've consumed
has been its most popular entries the
witcher 3 the wild hunt and the 2019
netflix show you're likely to have some
questions about a name often alluded to
but seldom expanded upon vessemir
geralt's old teacher in the witcher
video games vesamir has his own tragic
origin story which is the main focus of
the witcher nightmare of the wolf
bessemere spent his childhood as a
common street rat stealing food and coin
in order to get by while also serving a
rich master as a servant when a witcher
named deglin comes to exercise a monster
possessing a woman vasamir gets a taste
of the action and thirsts for more
offering himself his payment as part of
the law of surprise accustomed central
to witcher lore lionessa syndra that i
come to clean what is rightfully mine
for vettel
by the law of surprise
skipping way ahead to the end of this
particular adventure vesamir saddled
with the care of the remaining witchers
to be with most of the remaining
witchers missing or dead there are so
many questions related to this
cataclysmic event but the biggest ones
are what will happen to vesimir as fate
forces him to become the teacher he
doesn't want to be and how will that
affect the boys in his care
there's a lot of mystery and intrigue
surrounding all of these characters lady
zerps perhaps most of all she was a
childhood friend at besamers until he
decided to undergo the brutal and deadly
training of becoming a witcher leaving
her behind she did not however share
vesamir's humble status she's of noble
blood and rose through the ranks due to
careful political ploys and lucky
coincidences to eventually become an
esteemed advisor to the king after the
events of nightmare of the wolf however
tetra uses a powerful illusion to trick
vesimir into fatally wounding lady
zerpst who is now a 70 year old woman
bessemer who is of a similar age but
much younger looking due to the expanded
lifespan gifted to witchers tearfully
says goodbye to ladies zerps next to the
lake they dreamed of sharing together as
she dies in his arms at peace this might
seem to be a definite anti-lady's earp
story but then again she may appear as a
ghost wraith or other creature of the
underworld or we may get to go back in
time and see more of her story just who
exactly is lady zerps then how innocent
is she really we may never fully know
but we sure hope some piece of witcher
media expands on this woman's background
apparently named after the traditional
japanese onomatopoeia for a fox's cry
kitsu is an unnatural mutation of many
mysterious beings but often appears as a
deceptively cute fox she also however
appears as a tree spirit a basilisk and
perhaps even an elf like a fox kitsu is
one slight creature known for playing
tricks so it's impossible to fully know
what she is or isn't capable of however
we do believe she was created by deglin
in a series of unnatural unholy and
unethical experiments on various
creatures most of which died in the
process but a small number of whom
survived and escaped kitsu appears to be
one such creature who lashes out
humanity with the power she struggles to
control despite all that she is a
fundamentally well-meaning creature who
earns vessemer's sympathy and mercy
where is she now we can only guess but
we wouldn't be surprised to see more of
kitsu in the future perhaps even in
netflix's second season of the witcher
it would be quite the showdown as she
got on geralt's bad side
deglan grew up in the skeliga isles
where he was taught the worst lessons
from a young age never show fear or
mercy rule with an iron fist think of
your cause first yourself second and
everyone else dead last he's the
franchise's walking totem of toxic
masculinity like most characters in the
universe of the witcher however he's
still relatable even if he is the
closest thing to a villain in the movie
as a witcher himself he inspired vesimir
to take up the life he chooses and
trained him to become one of the
strongest witchers ever even if the
process nearly killed him he is the
morally great father figure to vesimir
as vesimir will become the morally great
father figure to geralt however he
crosses the line when he creates the
demented tortured monstrous mutants
including kitsu he intends to stick
these tortured creations on the
unsuspecting humans who would then have
no choice but to provide more coin to
witchers in order to eradicate them it's
an ingenious evil plan until vesimir
puts a stop to it killing deglin in the
process or in any spiritual hauntings or
miraculous recoveries this appears to be
the end of the tale of declan but we
still have much to learn about his own
origins will we ever learn the exact
chilling details of what made deglin
become such a twisted person we aren't
holding our breath but one can't dream
after everything however nightmare of
the wolf has one last ace up its sleeve
the seemingly inconsequential bald kid
who runs away from kare morin along with
the other boys too young to fight is
actually none other than geralt the
famous witcher who acts as the main
character of both the netflix series and
the video games alongside geralt appear
to be remus tomas and luca it's a lot of
names to keep track of but we can at
least guess where some of his friends
end up remus appears in the netflix live
action series as a freelance witcher so
you can find out what happens to him
there he couldn't find much on tomas
suggesting that he may have died as a
common casualty of the witcher creating
process as for luca the official netflix
witcher page about him says he quote
realized early on that the witcher life
wasn't for him so it sounds like he's
retired of course geralt's story is
always being shaped and twisted by
whoever gets the privilege to tell it
the next big chapter however will be the
second season of netflix's series the
witcher which debuts exclusively on the
streaming platform december 17th check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about the
witcher are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]